representative I'm sorry I'm having
trouble understanding you could you
representative your call is important to
us please hold
on give me some help here I just have
one simple
question so you've probably been through
a similar situation where you needed to
get through to a live person you had to
wait through 27 menu options just to get
to a human who could help you or what
happens to me sometimes you end up in a
dead end you have to hang up call back
start the whole process over these
customer service systems have the
audacity to try and train you but you're
the customer so many of those times it's
a simple transaction that can be handled
faster and more securely through a
virtual assistant particularly as these
Technologies are advancing and infused
with artificial
intelligence I'm sorry I'm having
trouble understanding you could you
repeat that
yeah exactly get me to the solution to
my issue without having to repeat myself
three
times here are three reasons why you
should build an omni Channel virtual
assistant
today let's talk about
skills hiring a new customer service
representative is going to take a ton of
time not to mention think about if you
have customers all around the globe
you're going to need access
247 so question for
you what if you could take your top
customer service representative and have
them train a chatbot with everything
they know this is possible with Watson X
assistant you don't have to have any
technical expertise you don't have to
know how to write code you just bring
your subject matter experts and use the
simple
gooey so next very important let's talk
about
cost think about how much it costs to
actually hire and train and maintain a
customer service representative that
initial list is going to be very high
now compare that to the cost of
deploying and maintaining a virtual
assistant that's going to be
significantly less and very cool you can
build this in just one
day now let's talk about the most
important thing our customers they
should be our number one priority so
customers are not going to want to wait
in a queue for 20 minutes just to get a
simple answer nor do they want to
memorize 27 different menu options just
to get to that answer they want their
answers fast and we want Happy customers
now something important to note is that
our customer representatives are not
going to be replaced by these chat Bots
our customer service representatives are
going to be held for more complex
answers that may require a little bit of
a human touch so if you look at the
framework chatbots help with your most
valuable resources time and attention
resources and funding and most
importantly your
customers if you'd like to learn more
consider these other videos on chatbots
or take some training so you can build
your own chatbot using artificial
intelligence at the link below I'm sorry
I'm having trouble understanding you
could you repeat
that